- What's up y'all, I'm back
with the Black Widows herself,
Scarlett Johansson, give it up!
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Black Widows are bad-ass, but
they're also a little creepy.
So in honor of Scarlet's new Marvel movie,
it's time to play,
what's creeping up on me.
(upbeat music)
♪ What's creepin' up on me? ♪
(laughs and applause)
I love that one.
Jessica that's awesome. How
competitive are you Scarlet?
- I'm pretty competitive,
especially when it comes to gaming.
- Yes, there is no other
answer for me on that question.
So while we're on the
same team in this game,
which is good because you know,
now Scarlet's having
technical difficulties,
which happens almost every
other show in the world
of now COVID TV. So
we're going to just have
to improvise this game
like they do on SNL.
So here's what will happen.
I will have a green screen behind me,
I can't see what's in my screen.
So Scarlet will give me clues
about what's creeping up on me
without saying the name of the thing.
I can pass if one is too hard
and if we can correctly guess 10 things
in one, two minute round,
the audience will win a cool prize.
Now I have no doubt on this, zero doubt.
We, are you ready?
- Okay. God, I'm sweating.
I have like flop, sweat.
- Oh my God. It's gonna be good.
Like little sweats good,
little nerves are good.
- [Kelly] Okay. Go.
- What is that? Oh gosh, it
looks like a big, there's...
(chuckles)
It flies, it looks like a flying lizard.
- Dragon! (ding)
- Oh, it makes honey...
- Bees, bees! (ding)
- Oh, Mark Ruffalo, plays this guy.
He has an anger management problem.
- Hulk! (ding)
- Whoa! This is scary.
It's hairy. And it's got big fangs
and it stands on two feet,
and wears those little shorts.
- Werewolf! (ding)
- Yes. Oh, it's flying.
And it likes fruit and
vampires turned into it.
- Bats! (ding)
- Yes.
Wait. Okay. It is so fun, love you.
Oh, what the heck is that?
I can't. Oh, that's cute.
Okay. It's a 101 of them.
- Dalmatians! (ding)
- Yeah. Great. Is that what it is?
Oh, it's like it kind of, you can this.
- Robots! (ding)
- Oh, yummy. I like this.
It's noodles and there's cheese on it.
- Fettuccine! (ding)
- Whoa. These come from
outer space. They have big...
- Aliens! (ding)
- Oh gosh. That's it's got eight legs,
it's crawling.
- Spiders!
- No, it is a type of that.
- Tarantula!
- I played one,
- Black Widow! (horns honking)
Whoa! I said Black Widow!
(audience cheering and applause)
I was like, I literally was thinking like,
I grew up around Tarantulas in Texas.
I don't know why I said
at first, we did it.
I hope you see the footage
of you when you see things,
your expression when you see
the pictures, it's amazing.
You have stories for
each one, it was awesome.
Okay. So we're amazing, audience.
And that means, that every one
of y'all is a winner as well.
So the Hypervolt Go is in an
affordable, ultra lightweight,
portable massager made
with simplicity in mind,
it's made by Hyperice, an industry leader
in recovery technology and
everyone in the house seat
is getting one. (horn honking) (applause)
Thank you for playing
Scarlet. We were awesome.
- I think we were awesome,
and then also those massage gun things,
those are no joke.
You could do some serious
damage with those. (chuckles)
- [Kelly] I know, I love them.
All right, everybody Black
Widow is out in theaters,
and on Disney plus with
premier access this Friday.